FOUNDER AND BILLIONAIRE, SIR
RICHARD BRANSON AND VIRGIN ORBIT
CEO DAN HART.
SIR RICHARD, LET ME START WITH
YOU.
WHAT WILL THESE SATELLITES BE
DOING?
>> OH, THEY WILL BE DOING A LOT
OF DIFFERENT THINGS.
THEY WILL BE MONITORING
AGRICULTURE IS ONE THING.
THEY WILL BE THE MINISTRY OF
DEFENSE WILL BE PUTTING
SATELLITES UP TO MAKE SURE THAT,
YOU KNOW, SHOULD SATELLITES BE
KNOCKED DOWN IN CERTAIN PARTS OF
THE WORLD THEY CAN BE REPLACED
QUICKLY.
SO THE EXCITING THING ABOUT
VIRGIN ORBIT IS IT CAN FLY TO
ANYWHERE IN THE WORLD.
IT CAN LAUNCH INTO ANY ORBIT AT
ANY TIME.
AND THAT'S THE FIRST TIME THAT
HAS HAPPENED.
IT'S NOW DONE IT THREE TIMES IN
A ROW VERY SUCCESSFULLY AND SO I
THINK, YOU KNOW, PEOPLE WHO NEED
TO GET SATELLITES UP THERE NOW
KNOW THAT THEY HAVE THIS OPTION
THAT ANY COUNTRY IN THE WORLD
CAN NOW LAUNCH SATELLITES
THROUGH VIRGIN ORBIT.
>> DAN, VIRGIN ORBIT RETROFITTED
747 SHOOTS THE SATELLITES FROM
ROCKETS IN THE WING OF THE
PLANE.
THAT SOUNDS DANGEROUS.
WALK US THROUGH THE PREPARATION
AND SAFETY METHODS FOR LAURENING
LAUNCHING THESE SMALL PIECES OF
TECH.
>> WE MAKE SURE EVERYTHING IS
GOOD TO GO AND HEALTHY.
WE FLY THE 747 OUT TO SEA TO
MAKE SURE THAT WHEN THE ROCKET
FLIES IT'S IN A SAFE PLACE.
WE VERIFY THAT IT'S GOOD TO GO
AND THEN WE RELEASE THE ROCKET.
THE ROCKET WAITS A NUMBER OF
SECONDS BEFORE IT LIGHTS ITS
ENGINES AND THEN GOES ACTIVE AND
CLIMBS UP.
SO EVERY PART OF THE PROCESS IS
MONITORED AND IS DESIGNED FOR A
SAFE, SUCCESSFUL FLIGHT.
AND I WILL ADD THAT THIS FLIGHT
THAT WE JUST DID COULD NOT HAVE
BEEN DONE WITH A GROUND LAUNCH
ROCKET IN CALIFORNIA.
BOTH THE ORBIT THAT WE ACHIEVED
WAS THE FIRST TIME THIS ORBIT
HAS EVER BEEN ACHIEVED FROM
>> IN NOVEMBER, RUSSIA BLEW UP
ONE OF THEIR OWN SATELLITES AS A
TEST, IT WAS CONDEMNED AS
RECKLESS.
THERE ARE SHOWS OF SATELLITES
ORBITING THE EARTH AT THIS
MOMENT.
WHY LAUNCH MORE?
>> WELL, JUST TO LET YOU KNOW,
ONE OF THE SATELLITES THAT WE
PUT UP YESTERDAY IS DESIGNED TO
MOP UP DEBRIS IN SPACE.
AND THAT'S ONE OF THE JOBS THAT,
YOU KNOW, PEOPLE WHO ARE, YOU
KNOW, WORKING WITH US, ARE
WORKING HARD ON, TO MAKE SURE
THAT IF THERE IS ANY DEBRIS
CREATED IN SPACE, IT CAN BE GOT
RID OF.
WHY DO WE NEED MORE SATELLITES?
WE NEED THEM FOR CONNECTIVITY,
FOR MONITORING RAINFORESTS,
ILLEGAL FISHING, AGRICULTURE.
THERE'S THOUSANDS OF BENEFITS
FOR MANKIND BACK ON EARTH.
SPACE IS BIG, THERE'S STILL
PLENTY OF ROOM FOR A LOT MORE
SATELLITES.
AND WITH LOW EARTH ORBIT
SATELLITES, THEY WILL COME OUT
OF SPACE EVERY FIVE YEARS, THEY
NEED TO BE REPLACED.
THAT'S ONE OF THE OTHER BIG
ADVANTAGES THAT VIRG